c'est la fin idéale
j'attends ta son journal pour lire l ol
j'espère qu'elles seront tous assurés
frei a remporté à narrer barzi bave sur
outils des ptic romera le petit écho de
la forêt c'est un très sévère ou là il y
à toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
dissection ça vous le découvrirez dans
le tue des cours de l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voici une nouvelle qui a un nouvel les
nouvelles et coûter cher téléphone deux
oiseaux célèbres ont entrepris le tour
du monde
et oui les oiseaux vivent tous si avec
leur tour à tour du monde le tour du
monde
adèle de la cigogne avec pis pour le
peso a relaté et believe you lie le
petit écho de la forêt à part des le
nouvel avait bien vite fait le tour de
notre forêt ça fait combien de
kilomètres le tour du monde
le tour du monde fait plus de 40000 km
toi tout ce qu à ouaga plus comme on le
sait alors nous ne pas être tout le
monde ou pia pia club
ou comment est aussi le tour du monde de
nos deux amis ils vont traverser les
eaux ses amis les maires les cinq
continents l'europe l'afrique l'amérique
l'asie et un level games et adolescents
le boulot à l'orgue
c'est visible l'océanie et j'allais le
dire ils vont voyager au paquebot un
bateau à voile
nous tous les avions en avion impossible
de 20,6 à l'anglais monti zip tube
likabet les pipots son guide oiseaux et
a alors ils n'ont pas besoin d'avions
pour voler le lendemain matin
boris lui réveillé en sursaut
et qui est acquis c'est six mois il a
adoré
mais qui est ce qui est arrivé à vous
êtes valley nous battons vous parti ni
où l on fait tous les deux la tôle du
monde comme tout le monde moi est même
très bien alors pourquoi toi côté tosca
pour que vous preniez votre élan en
étant pour le coiffeur nous a volés mais
moi pas pouvoir vols commencent à moi
pas voir l moi être loupé à oiseaux sais
qui vous êtes comme ça un lien moi j'ai
une idée qu'elle est dû si vous
appreniez avoli mois avoir essayé avec
pipo mois est retombée à 1,6 km de là et
si les frères k stores tu mettais désert
du avoir essayé moi et triton people ou
moi j'ai une idée divine oui et si ça
dort à transporter boris sur son dos
tres pour nous il n'est pas question où
est très contrariante
moi j'ai laquelle fait le tour du monde
à pied pour les méthodes les listings
est très maladroit alors moi l'idée
laquelle j'étais un avion il n'en est
pas question
vous êtes traité tout le soir venu ils à
doha et boris se retrouvèrent au clair
de lune
qu'elle est belle et soieries de l'ubs
quel beau paysage et rue pour crier
parce que vous vouliez mobilisés à faire
le toit du monde et connaissez bien ici
cher guerriers de même à plein de la
volée cherisey draps elle passe son
temps à se contredire
nullement vous non pas trop elle est si
frappante à bien tous chers téléphone
pour une nouvelle édition du petit écho
de la forêt